my guests tonight are the director and
the cast of the upcoming film Aquaman
please welcome Patrick Wilson yeah yeah
I'm doing my team a second
[Applause]
thanks to being here have you look at
this look what you're wearing that's
incredible and I feel like the native
mr. t yeah that's gorgeous
or just for your show oh my god rub
again rub again a little Big Bear that
felt really good we have a lot to talk
about James first of all in the past
Aquaman I don't think has sometimes
gotten the respect that Aquaman is due
mostly because I believe how he was
treated by the cartoon Super Friends all
right I think we're all familiar with
this was the depiction of Aquaman did I
grew up by the way if that's not in the
movie I'm gonna be enraged you know what
yeah could be in the movie you just have
to wait and see yeah this is what I can
see okay very good but but I mean how do
you you take it's a bit of a challenge
you've got to recast in a way you know
Aquaman and I think that I think you'd
be very successful at it and people are
very stoked about it but it's necessary
that Aquaman be brought who take that
image when we bring him into the future
yeah I think you know one of the biggest
things that that Zack did was casting
Jason in that role I mean the moment you
cast Jason and they're off Aquaman
listen no one's gonna go up to this guy
and make
now I think we have a picture here of
the new Aquaman I know there's been
getting out there by James James I've
been looking at that picture and it
looks to me like Aquaman is wearing
denim underwater is he or is he not
making a very poor choice to wear denim
underwater firstly I want to say I tried
to get Jason to do it pantsless yes but
uh that was my first choice yeah it was
his idea to go for denim
yes and and you like it you're very
comfortable with the outfit that that
Aquaman had yeah but denim was a bad
choice
phenomenal looks great but when it's wet
it is yeah yes sexy the way of saying it
my question is did you ever for a second
do you guys ever for a second think of
like board shorts or something like that
yeah sure sweet it was right come on
it's a long story but about four girls
how were a 1920s bathing suit when I go
to the beach every single inch of me is
cover
you